I want you to look at these two numbers
here 46 million versus 30 million 46
million 30 million what does that mean
to you in a second maybe a minute I'll
share with you what those two numbers
mean and you will be shell-shocked on
what industry is booming based on those
numbers on top of all the other digital
media trends that are taking place I'll
share some of them with you the reason
why I'm doing this video here is because
if there's ever been a time in a market
where it's business capitalism
entrepreneurship you're trying to make a
name for yourself in a very loud noisy
industry where the dominant names have
been created today's probably the best
time this is why this is why Heraclitus
a famous Greek philosopher once said the
only thing that's constant is change
change is only thing that's constant
things are changing today so fast and
those who learn how to adapt and make
adjustments and pivots faster are gonna
flourish post 2019 so today in this
episode we're gonna talk about top
digital media trends one of the things
I'm gonna give you about a time this
video is over would is couple links I
want you to go look at it's gonna be a
little bit more of an extensive report
because I could have done this video for
3-4 hours but I'm giving you the basic
stuff that maybe you ought to be paying
attention to and a couple of the
articles and a video for you to watch so
having said that let's start off with
the biggest social media name everybody
knows Facebook and what's been happening
with Facebook lately first of all 74
percent of users on Facebook are women
think about that well 62 percent are men
so when they did a survey saying how
many women or how many men are on
Facebook seventy-four percent of woman
said yes I do 62 percent said I'm on
Facebook on a daily basis right so
that's interesting to know the
demographic on who you're trying to
market to and and attract age wise not
much has changed a little bit change in
the last couple years thirteen to
seventeen year olds on Facebook that's
three percent 18 to 24 year old that's
around 17 percent 25 to 34 is the
biggest audience they have 25 percent is
between 8 25 to 34 years old here's the
kicker that you gotta look at 54 percent
of all of Facebook users are above 35
years old
let me say this one more time 54% of all
of Facebook users are about 35 years old
what does this mean to you I want to
give you a metaphor and analogy that
hopefully this will make sense to you
imagine if you go into a party or a
nightclub okay there is some clubs that
are 18 and over parties that are 18 and
over right some that are 21 and over
some you go to they're like executive
some do you go to their thirty some
forty fifty if you go to the club of
Facebook it's going to be people about
thirty five years old which means
they're gonna be listening to 80s music
maybe old-school hip-hop that kind of
stuff
that's the audience there then you
continue 35 to 44 18 percent 45 to 54 15
percent 55-64 12 percent 65 and up 9
percent you know what it tells you 21
percent of Facebook users are about 55
years old so that's a big number so
imagine if you're a market or
demographic or wanting to find that 55
year-olds Facebook is still a great
dbest market for you to find 55 plus
year olds on the needs that they may
have whatever product you're selling now
here's a couple things that's taking
place globally with Facebook users
globally you'll kind of see where it's
growing really fast and where it's flat
this is Q 3/4 q3 users logging in 2012
vs. q3 2018 6 years let's see what
happened US Canada q3 2012 189 million
q3 2018 242 million the increase may be
53 million people that's not a big
increase that's actually flat right
Europe 253 million today 375 million
good increase bigger than US and Canada
but still not a big increase 120 million
increase look at the rest of the world
288 million to 736 million massive
increase but nothing is close to a pack
which is asia-pacific 277 million to 917
million
that's more than 3x on what's happening
on a pack so Facebook just like you
being a business owner entrepreneur is
sitting there saying what is our
capacity in US Canada
what is our capacity in Europe what's
growing and they're starting to realize
we're a Packers we'll talk a little bit
more about a pack you in a minute
when we go to some other data you'll be
blown away on what's taking place here
so that's some of the stuff with
Facebook now one of the things that took
place that's been changing lately is for
the longest time you and I would log on
to Facebook more than any other website
Facebook was number one so you would ask
which of these websites do you log onto
on a daily basis people would say number
one is Facebook but it's changed number
one today is officially YouTube's 73
percent of users say every day I log on
to YouTube think about it for yourself
what percentage are you 73 percent say
I'm always on YouTube 68 percent
Facebook 35 percent Instagram instagrams
come up tremendously and anyhow
Pinterest a lot of us don't pay
attention to Pinterest Pinterest 29%
snapchat is still up there 27 percent
linked in 25 percent I I still I still
see LinkedIn having the biggest I see
LinkedIn for entrepreneurs and business
people being a massive vertical to pay
attention to 25 percent Twitter's 24
percent what's app is 22 percent Twitter
believe it or not 24 percent so those
are the numbers on what's taking place
so now let's look at stories you know a
lot of people are like well you know I
don't know if I really wanted to
snapchat stories or Instagram stories or
I don't know if I want to do Instagram
stories it doesn't seem like it's gonna
be that crazy look at the numbers 400
million stories are sent every day on
Instagram
400 million every day number 2 is
snapped at 186 million snap came out
with stories now Instagram does more
stories than snapped us 186 Facebook
Facebook stories most of us don't use it
it's still a hundred 50 million stories
on a daily basis
facebook Messenger 70 million and
Facebook is trying to combine messengers
stories Instagram whatsapp all of it
under the same platform which that's
gonna make it very very the amount of
power Facebook is gonna be able to have
I know they're dealing with a lot of
their security and all these other son
stuff that they're dealing when they're
gonna continue facing there's gonna be a
lot of scrutiny they're gonna face but
Facebook is still the juggernaut and
Mark Zuckerberg is still and actively
involved CEO that wants to compete on a
marketplace he's not a guy that's golf
in six seven days a week he said again
trying to make Facebook better and more
competitive he has some issues they got
a lot of privacy
shoes that the consumers trust has gone
down with Facebook the numbers prove
people have lost a lot of trust with
Facebook but having said that it is
still a behavior that you and I have on
a daily basis and they know that right
so stories is up there one of the ones
that came out recently YouTube about a
year and a half ago a year ago when you
started doing stories LinkedIn is also
about to come out with stories they're
doing a little bit of that but this is
not going away again do you remember
what I said if you went to a club called
Facebook the average person at that
nightclub is gonna be about 35 years old
fifty four percent if you go into the
club of stories this club is filled with
20 year olds so do you want 20 year old
customers or do you want 35 40 50 year
old customers it all depends on who
you're going after them by the way this
club is also the 14 15 16 year-olds that
5 10 years from now are going to
remember you and stay emotionally
connected to your brand if you stay with
them and stay loyal to them they'll be
with you 10 years from now when they
turn 28 years old 27 years old something
to paint it pay attention to so now
let's talk a little bit about cable TV
subscription video on demand and as well
as advertising video on demand just to
kind of tell you what's advertising and
you know subscription subscription is
more like the Netflix Hulu you know
advertising video demand would be
YouTube so now today user-based Netflix
is still at the top then it's Amazon
Prime number two then it's Hulu then HBO
now believe it or not then sling came up
DirecTV now Hulu Live and YouTube is
still not up there YouTube is number
eight YouTube is actually you know
trying to do the subscription thing with
YouTube red and some of these other
things that they're doing but they're
trying to look at right now saying what
is our blue ocean because just like
Google Plus try to compete with Facebook
saying we have the biggest platform we
can easily compete with Facebook and
beat them because everybody logs onto
Google every day and no one did anything
with Facebook YouTube is kind of
starting to sit down and say wait a
minute we are we're an advertising video
on demand where people can go out and
watch content why are we not doing good
with subscription-based and a lot of
that has to do with original series
they're actually thinking about doing an
original series what eye charging you
for like you don't have to do like a you
know the big original series narcos all
these things that they're doing if they
want to go in the direction
do an original series except for free
complete different approach they want to
take because the advertisers will spend
more money on the original series so
we'll see what YouTube is gonna do
obviously YouTube is ran by a couple
brilliant people but a lot of brilliant
minds in that company at Google they're
not gonna be forgotten about they're
gonna do something there that's
something to be thinking about alright
so the next time one take a look at his
cable TV here's what's happened with
cable TV in the last five years they
lost ten million users very simple from
2013 that 103 million users today they
have 93 million users projector to get
to the 70 million users in the next 10
years and by the way very obvious what's
taking place no one's playing a guessing
game saying oh my gosh I'm surprised but
I want you to be thinking about this
remember how I said if you go to a
Facebook Club the average person that
attends that clubs gonna be above 35
years old 54% going to be above 35 if
you go to stories it's gonna be 20s and
some teenagers will show up if you go to
a nightclub hosted by cable TV the
average of 10 is gonna be 50 to 55 years
old and higher just so you know that's
the viewership that they have but
businesses still know that there's a lot
of value for cable TV there's still
advertising there's to put in the money
behind it Super Bowl commercial ads 30
seconds is 5.3 million dollars last year
I think was 5.2 4 million dollars so
it's not like it's droppin or it's going
up companies are still wanting to spend
money although one of the biggest brands
in the world one of the biggest brands
most recognizable brand in the world has
decided to not do halftime Super Bowl
commercial this year for the first time
in over ten years and that's Coca Cola
their idea is a complete different thing
they want to do they want to bring the
country together by doing a commercial
right before the national anthem the
message is towards what happened with
the NFL two years ago with Colin
Kaepernick they kind of want to bring
America together so Schumer you know all
the issues were facing with Pelosi Trump
the wall Republicans Democrats CNN MSNBC
Fox what can we do to bring America
together Jeep did this a couple years
ago where the commercial was a massive
hit if they go that approach I think
coca-cola is gonna come out a winner
here for cable TV but we'll see what
happened there here's another number to
be looking at digital ads on videos
online videos has gone from four billion
2010 to 35 billion in 2018 that's 9x
in a span of eight years that's a lot
that means companies are spending money
on video realizing it's a good idea for
us advertising the YouTube it is a good
idea for us to advertise on Facebook it
is a good idea people are there they're
watching it so what about us spending
more money they're fully trusting on
what's taking place by the way it's
estimated for this 35 billion will go to
90 billion in the next five to seven
years so that thing is not slowing down
having said that ad blocking ad blocking
is something that different generations
are better at let me explain according
to the research that I have which I'll
give you a link to look at 40 million
Millennials know how to block ads better
than any other generation forty million
Millennials block ads only 20 million
Gen X's and the 11 million baby boomers
so you can see which generation is more
tolerant for ads versus the generation
that isn't tolerant for ads but
regardless of what's taking place
there's still ads taking place but they
also know how to block the ads
generation by generation by generation
that takes me to the next part of length
consumption you know a lot of times if
you hired a marketing firm back in 2010
2012 2013 they would tell you making
long videos is not good the best format
for videos is three minutes your videos
are too long we hire this marketing
agency your videos are way too long
people don't like 20 minute videos
people like three minute videos and
today yours later we said you know what
we're sticking to this yours later today
our biggest viewed videos millions of
views video they're all over an hour 20
minutes 30 minutes 40 minutes and
everybody's like what happened here into
some other shorter format videos we did
28,000 19,000 42,000 so the whole idea
about length is there really truth
behind it a lot of people thought there
is let me show you what's happened the
last two years three different examples
I got for you these are short formatted
videos 0 to 5 minutes
medium formatted videos 5 to 20 minutes
and then long-form videos 20 plus
minutes q1 2016 is the orange q1 2018 is
the red ready short we went from 55% of
videos being 0 to 5 minutes in q1 of
2016 to 38% we're making fewer shorter
videos than we did back then medium has
gone from 16%
in 2016 - now 9% however the only one
that's on an uptick is the long format
videos 20 minutes plus it has gone from
29% to 54% why because viewers have told
content creators if you're content
you're creating this value-based I will
watch it if it's not I'm not gonna watch
it this is one of the reasons well I
think the one video you need to watch is
the video I made saying ten rules for
content creators for entrepreneurs click
on a link over here to go watch that
video it'll kind of give you an idea on
how you need to be making content for
yourself that fits your model because if
you don't do it right it will fail you
if you do it right it'll benefit you so
the data about shorter videos I don't
know how much truth there is behind it
from 10 years ago people are starting to
say I want long format videos by the way
here's the kicker for some of you guys
that are podcasters the data the report
that I'll send you for you to watch the
report on the podcasts to watch that are
the long podcast people are not liking
longer podcast today - the guys in the
marketplace that are doing very very
good and there's about 100 of them
everybody else that's trying to get in
the podcast form to do a our two-hour
three-hour podcast users are saying I
can't stay on there for too long however
the podcasts the new ones that are all
of a sudden excelling our formats of 24
minutes 16 minutes 18 minutes 12 minutes
podcasts that only twelve minutes 14 24
minutes people are starting to like them
obviously number one podcast still
around the world is NPR and then you
have some of the other guys that's out
there but the main whites individual is
Joe Rogan he's doing a very good job
with the podcast crushing the game
himself but for the people that are
trying to get into it our formatted
podcast may not favor you right now
video slightly different because I'm
watching I'm listening I'm feeling
podcast I'm just listening right so
that's the formatting there now a couple
other numbers add in media buying where
should you advertise this was a media
summit that took place earlier in 2018
and all buyers were there and they asked
them a question
ranking 1 to 5 which one of these
platforms are priority to you to
advertise one be an exploratory 5 being
most important here's what they scored
Google at the top 4.6 it's above
Facebook 4.1 insta
is number three with 3.6 how wild is
that insta is number three are three
point six YouTube number four with three
point two LinkedIn linked in linked in
is fifth place at two point two
Pinterest two point one Amazon is coming
up like you wouldn't believe
Amazon's gonna get into the ads game
like never before they they are already
in the subscription game but they're
getting in the ad game as well now
there's three different places for
people to advertise on Amazon they're
gonna get that money as well then you
have snap 1.9 and then you have Twitter
at the bottom with 1.7 so something for
you to be thinking about that Google is
still at the top then it is you know you
have Facebook Institute the one number
that a lot of people don't pay attention
to it I'd pay very close attention to
two numbers to stats instant in LinkedIn
insta and LinkedIn there is a lot going
on there I know a lot of you already
take advantage of it if you're not you
got to start really researching more
instant putting your game plan around
LinkedIn and instead if that's where
your customers are gonna be at okay
having said that let's look at some
global trends let's have some fun here
this is pretty wild I mean I was in
India earlier in 2018 and spoke in front
of a 5,000 people to the IIT Institute
and I was there with former chairman of
State Bank of India it's got like two
hundred forty thousand employees and we
spoke to the engineers and I gave them a
message I said listen I want you to
realize what's happening right now in
India with the ideas of capitalism
entrepreneurship all this of what's been
happening with India the level of hunger
and you guys are produced on some of the
best engineers in the world American
companies are hiring engineers from
India I went to an insurance company the
entire floor there was 200 engineers
working on this on this floor the entire
floor if I told you 80% was Indian I'd
be off more than 80% they were all
Indian I said why says I love hiring
people from IIT they come here we want
them all they're so amazing engineers
they're the best engineers we recruit
them on board right but watch his
numbers um what's been taking place so
global trends Internet users China
versus India India started late with
Internet users in 2010 China had 457
million Internet users India had only 63
million that's a big difference by the
way these are the top two countries in
the world pop
my number one Indian number two I think
China's ahead of India by like a couple
hundred million people right for 57 to
63 look what happens here 2018 eight
years later China eight hundred two
million India 431 million percentage of
growth China 75 percent India's growth
is four hundred and eighty four percent
they grew their users by four hundred
nine I wouldn't I wouldn't sit there and
just say India's not a market to pay
attention to let me give you a whole
different number here PewDiePie versus
t-series t-series is like the channel in
India for music music videos all this
stuff right in 2017 January PewDiePie
had 51 million subscribers t-series only
had 14.5 million subscribers as of right
now today whatever today's date is like
January 25th 2019 PewDiePie is at 82
million small lead over t-series 82
million why market is massive in India
and they're learning about capitalism
entrepreneurship business the Prime
Minister the president there believes in
capitalism and is pushing it and the
younger generation is eating this stuff
up but they're just learning can you
imagine if India actually really starts
competing what could happen with their
GDP I did a cup a video a couple videos
ago talking about where they rank for
GDP you're gonna see a lot of stuff
happening here by the way the one thing
about India you gotta realize this they
have less regulation about being on
other sides versus China China keeps
everybody internal India actually allows
people to go on YouTube and Instagram
not a lot of it here they're like
control they're like every one of their
social media apps to be through theirs
most of them do they got an app that
just came out I think it's called toku
it's like a musically with snapchat and
Instagram combined in 2018 first half
they're number one and the most apps
downloaded for China over 101 million
over every other app downloaded and in
the first half of 2018 so they're
competing but it's internal in India
does it with every other country around
the world I see something happening here
with India maybe not like a year think
it could be a three five ten year thing
to be paying attention to last but not
least remember when I said earlier there
was two numbers 46 million versus 30
million 46 million 30 million ready
here's what that is 40
six million viewers logged on to watch
the League of Legends World Championship
game that's eSports 46 million people
around the world logged on to watch the
League of Legends World Championship
game you know what was 30 million 30
million people around the world watched
the NBA championship game 30 million
versus 46 million
eSports guess what in the age category
of 18 to 34 percentage of viewers of
each category 18 to 34 you know what is
the most viewed sport for each category
of 18 to 34 percentage-wise
the age category ready eSports number
one sixty two percent 60 eSports is
bigger than soccer 46% worldwide it's
bigger than basketball 36 percent bigger
than hockey 29 percent 10 is 28% NFL 28%
Major League Baseball 26 percent golf 21
percent eSports last year budget was two
hundred nine hundred six million dollars
in revenues up 38 percent these sports
is here and you're going to see a lot of
kids advertisers realize hey we but we
better start paying attention to this
year if we want buyers of 18 to 34 we
better pay attention to what eSports and
by the way I got a lot of stats to give
you on eSports
I would be able to fill up all over the
place if I were to give it to you but
I'm not gonna do that the part that you
need to know about eSports 380 million
total viewers around the world
380 million total viewers around the
world who follow esports and they
actually watch it these are not all
gamers some of them are just those who
watch it on what's taking place so by
the way all this data everything you got
from today's video means nothing unless
if you have a strategy to implement and
help grow your business do you remember
earlier when I said this is the best
time ever for a small business owner to
compete with the bigger companies
because of adapting change in putting
something in place today you could be
the India story of going from 63 million
users versus China's 457 to having the
biggest percentage of growth this ought
to be you putting a plan together to
compete
percentage-wise against the biggest
competitors in your marketplace how do
you do it I got 5 points for your number
one first thing you got to do is
identify exactly who your ideal
customers number one because once you
know who your ideal customer is the next
thing is what which platform do they
hang out at the most so I need to be
there if I'm looking for this age
category it's Facebook if I'm looking
for younger it's stories if I'm looking
for older maybe cable if I'm looking for
you know 30 year olds for it maybe
YouTube but I need to know that so
number one is who your ideal customers
number two is going to be your platform
number three content look if you're
still not creating content in 2019 you
are being left behind listen I am NOT
asking you to create content every day I
don't create content every day on
YouTube you know I I don't do it every
day I have a schedule and I started off
with once a week and I work my way up
the the thing I recommend to you is put
a calendar in 2019 and stick to it
here's what I mean if you don't think
you can do once a day if you don't think
can do once a week do once a month but
no matter what you're doing it once a
month if you can write an article Sunday
nights and post it on your website for
people to read start Sunday nights but
whatever you're doing create a calendar
for content creation the video I told
you earlier 10 steps on how to create
content what's the title that video
Mario was the 10 10 rules for creating
content we put the link over here go
watch that video actually go through it
and start realizing what is your
strategy on how to create content for
you so number one customer number two is
platform number 3 is content number 4
budget once you know your customer once
you know the platform once you're
creating content then have a budget for
you to get exposed if your audience is
instant spend some money there if your
audience is Facebook spend some money if
it's YouTube spend some money to put a
percentage of what you're gonna be doing
to make a name for yourself in a last
but not least position positioning gives
you knowing as a small business owner if
I want to compete with the marketplace
how do i position myself to compete if i
go compete with the person let's just
say I'm the best at uppercuts and you
want to come and meet with uppercuts
you're gonna lose but maybe you have to
work with speed maybe you have to work
with kick maybe you have to work with
something else I made a video I think a
year and a half two years ago called how
to compete with bigger companies size
versus position it's a short 10 15
minute video for you to watch
give you strategy on how to do that if
you haven't watched a click over here
how to compete with bigger companies
having said all of that if you are not
registered for the vault conference the
three-day conference we're hosting right
here in Dallas we're entrepreneurs from
around the world already 35 countries
have registered from around the world to
come to Dallas Texas for 3 there's gonna
be the first of all Valley team and
conference will ever host entrepreneurs
marketer salespeople sea executives
founders startup entrepreneurs they're
all coming in the CEO package seats
already sold the founder package I think
there's 13 seats left to register for
that out of the 75 this event will be a
sellout if you're getting value from
things like this imagine this for 3 days
straight where we get clear on what you
need to do next to take your business to
the next level so if you haven't yet
registered for the conference click on a
link below or something over here that's
gonna look like the vault click on a go
get register so I can see you face to
face me you and your business partners
and running mates in Dallas Texas take
everybody bye-bye that was a quote state
a long time ago by Greek philosopher
here alligators got it got it my stomach
is killing me